all right so i've already been looking
at some of the classes kind of planning
out
part of me really wants to start is rich
but since i'm trying to make i want to
make it this character after albus
dumbledore so i think we almost have to
go astrologer
please choose a body type yeah type a
all right name here we go guys
let's see here
nope not that
[Music]
albus
oh should i put in the full name now
we'll just go with his first name
body type type hey age young now see
here
we're gonna go with old dumbledore
choose bass template oh my goodness
dumbledore we are looking rough
we are looking wait hold on
that's bass template okay yeah detailed
appearance here we go
oh wait can i not hear what it sounds
like
sample
[Music]
[Music]
that one feels more dumbledore to me
uh he is very old very old
all right face in here here we go okay
let's go to the hair first
and we're just gonna go with like aged
dumbledore here you know
we could go with young dumbledore i mean
with fantastic beasts and everything
what is this game about wow okay that's
a big question
you mean story-wise
[Music]
because i honestly don't know a whole
lot yet about this story i've tried to
uh
i know that george rr martin wrote part
of it i know in traditional
miyazaki fashion that it's gonna be
the story will probably be a little bit
more pronounced in this one than it has
been in the previous souls games
root darkness are you serious no we i'm
not gonna go through all of that
i'm not gonna go through all that we
will go through the overall hair though
let's see
oh dude okay we're getting we're getting
close here
we're getting close
all right let's see how many they have
total
they've got 27 total okay definite no
definite no okay that one right there 22
is a maybe
no we can't go with the bangs
22 or 20 but we first we've got to put
the beard on 13 dang double
dumbledore's been out in the wild for a
bit with this one
he has been out in the wild
oh my goodness all right let's see
that one looks kind of cool have it with
it pulled back like that
we can have him be a slightly younger
version all right i think pretty clearly
what i'm gonna have to see though
is i'm gonna have to see the facial hair
we really need to go with the full on
yeah here we go
there we go we've got to have the full
beard before we can tell
what uh everything else
how everything else needs to look here
all right so let's go yeah let's go back
to the hair now and just make sure this
was really not too bad
the bushy one looks more like hagrid's
hair yeah i want to do another play
through and make hagrid yeah there's
that's that's definitely a hagrid style
right there all right so right now
number 10 is in the lead just dumbledore
with it pulled back
okay that one no still too kind of
shaggy looking he's got you can't even
see most of his face all right so
there's 20.
see this is this is giving me too many
like
that might be it right there this 20 is
giving me too many like sauerman vibes
just looks too much like sauerman
and we need to change his skin color too
like he he's
way more fair-skinned
all right so 22
or
number 10 right there 22 yeah that's
kind of where i'm leaning
all right let's go 22 for now
and then let's go back to
yeah where i mean honestly guys like you
could spend so much time
just on this
you could spend so much time just
customizing the character it's kind of
insane really
okay let's see
that one is i mean i don't want him to
be whoa
dude there's the voldemort playthrough
right there oh my goodness that is like
chalk white
holy cow okay no no no no
[Music]
i think like right in here we give for
dumbledore
all right let's look at bot yeah see
like all this i i'm not gonna go through
okay now musculature we might actually
oh you only get two options
all right dumbledore i love the guy but
he i don't think anybody would describe
him as a as a very muscular man
all right so let's go back the only
other thing i really want to make sure
that we
change is we want to check the nose you
know we want to make sure he's got that
yeah we want to have that wizard that
long hooked nose nose depth maybe uh oh
there we go
yeah see i don't want it to okay that's
too much right there
[Music]
all right so yeah maybe like 175
nose ridge length we're at 128.
uh maybe 170.
no slant okay
we were at 70 to start oh yeah yeah yeah
dude here we go
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
all right that might be too big
go back down to about 110.
[Music]
oh man all right we're getting it we're
getting it and then nose tip height i'm
gonna take that one down just a bit more
take that one down just to about right
there
all right i'm liking it i'm liking it i
think we're getting close i'm i'm not
going to go through every single thing i
do want to do the eyes because we know
i know dumbledore has to have those
ears blue eyes
i'm gonna go with that one right there
all right there we go guys dumbledore
and now we are ready to jump in we've
got him set up as the astrologer class
so i think we're ready to go now
she's base template i i think we're good
oh man look at him dude
look at him inside there you can't even
really see his hair too much but it's
fine that's fine
all right let's go ahead and finish
all right let's head up i'm ready to get
outside man are we about to get out into
the open world
i told you guys i'm going to press x so
many time on doors yes here we go
lim grave our first look at it you guys
oh my goodness
just glorious man
just glorious all right let's go on this
way and it looks like we've got someone
here who wants to talk to us another
side of grace right here
uh yeah we already figured out the map
who are you oh yes
tarnished are we i'm dumbledore
dude it would be so fun to play this
game as an assassin
[Music]
really
armament ahead
oh wait what
so wait was that a treasure chest over
there
lord sworns
great sword let's go dude
let there be treasure chest it's like a
more heavily armored guy there kind of
in the middle
we'll see if we can't save him for last
okay he just turned around that's good
and then this guy over here is just
sitting down i think we're
we'll go after him next so let's try to
get this guy right here and then we'll
get the guy sitting down oh and then
there's another guy over there with a
torch okay i didn't know about him
all right he's getting close to being at
the point where he turns around yep
there we go
well dude he's got like a big horn on
the side of him
see if that alerts the other enemies
all right come on
no no no no no no
trying to go about this stealthily
all right did this guy go sit back down
he did
or no he didn't go sit back down but
he's standing over here now
[Music]
what are those things over there
did they follow me all the way from that
pool
no way
[Music]
all right let's see if we can get this
wolf with the magic
oh i missed him
oh one shot the wolf with magic all
right
good job albus
all right and i did notice there's
another enemy over here
i don't want to attract those
flying creatures whatever they are
no way
no way
all right rolling yeah yeah yeah
no
oh jesus
[Music]
no
oh my gosh
no open world is treacherous man
oh that was a big hit on him
nice okay we got him
all right
we could go and heal
but when we do that all of these enemies
are going to reset and there was one
more guy
[Music]
in fact i think it might be kind of like
the boss well not boss but sort of the
mini boss of this area
oh look at him he's way more armored
than the other guys
all right we'll wait for him to turn
around see if we can get a stealth hit
on him oh there he goes
oh man yeah his armor's a lot more shiny
oh there's another guy right there
though
and then there's more of those flying
things about oh man there's dudes
everywhere
we might just have to heal
at the sight of grace
i want to just clear this whole area
though you know
i'm going to try and clear this whole
little camp oh
freaking wolf man you've got to be
kidding me how does he not smell me i
don't know but i'm glad he doesn't
oh no way
no way
no way
no way you knew instantly where i was
dude
oh he's looking right at me
you got the wolf beside him oh yeah the
wolf's just like laying
there oh got both of them look at that
nice spell work there dumbledore
[Music]
oh my gosh he turned around
oh no he saw that
oh he is mad too
he is mad
josh rodriguez what's up dude also went
mage but cosplaying a standoff i love it
man
i'm about to die i need to stop reading
chat sorry
oh wow oh wow this guy is angry dude he
is so angry why is he so angry
why
relax man
this guy walking by
we do not want to mess with him until
the very end he absolutely wrecked us
and we weren't even really trying to
fight him we're just trying to run away
but look at this we've now
just kind of stumbled upon this secret
passage here pull out the torch
no enemy ahead i don't know if i believe
you
oh why can't i not open it oh wait
at first it was greyed out
did we just like sneak into this area
all right hold on we got to make sure
it's not a fake chest okay good
[Music]
adding skills with a whetstone knife you
can use ashes of war to grant your
armaments new skills at sites of grace
an armament can only have one skill any
skill that previously had will be
removed an armaments type determines
what skills it can have some special
armaments have unique skills and cannot
be granted new ones
so we just got ash of war storm stomp
come on hit him in the back with it
come on hit him in the back
yes
no not you
i don't want you i want you and only you
oh this might be our chance right here
no
okay nice we got him all right
now we attack you
all right not bad
need to get the backstab on him though
that's that's really where you're gonna
get
a lot of damage
all right kind of just feeling him out
seeing what sort of attack patterns he's
got no
no
oh he's quick at getting the shield back
up
that's for sure
yeah that one it takes away so much
stamina
oh that's the one
when he goes to that one that's the one
when you gotta get behind him
that one just dodged out of the way
what no i am shielding
oh my gosh this guy man this guy
so annoying
oh is he gonna okay all right this is
what we want anyway
yeah let all those other guys go away
go on going back to your day
see like
it's hard to get the
not the parry but it's hard to get the
that one
it's hard to get that on him because you
only have such a narrow window
oh oh i rolled away
yes let's go